ready right good evening to everyone
good evening to uh the members of the
committee and the members of the
executive that to come along and uh the
officers uh very pleased uh with with
with the
turnout and I think hopefully we'll have
a good meeting um firstly I just wish
everybody Happy New Year this is our
first meeting of scrutiny in the New
Year I hope hope it's a good one for all
of
you right you you you'll recognize that
we uh streaming live uh just to notify
you of that um and we'll go on to the
agenda and the first item on the agenda
is to note the
attendances have we had
any yeah apologies Miss from councilor
councilors jman Taylor Walsh and
Weston right thank
you any others
no right um item two is the minutes of
uh previous meetings um one on the 10th
of
July
um on the 20th of
September 10th of July 12th of July
right so it's three of it yeah I thought
it was
two
right um yeah
everybody had the reports the minutes
everything okay can we move them to
correct
record okay thanks item three's
Declaration of interest if any members
have got interest in um the items on the
agenda can you please raise that now
no uh item four questions from the
public my been re we have yeah yeah
we've not received any um right we we'll
go straight into the U main items on the
agenda um and the first one is a weeding
program uh read the wild in and greed uh
space
review so Steve are you yeah I'll just
Inu then hand over to the offices for
the presentation so yes uh obviously I
think we are quite pleased to be with
here tonight uh since uh I sort of took
over this program a few years ago now
it's it's changed quite a lot and
obviously with things like climate
change and other things sort of
affecting the work it it's had quite a
lot of changes I think particularly in
the last year with the proposals we now
want to take forward to next year I
think think it's obviously quite is
particularly the right time to me this
before this committee here so we can
actually look at all those changes why
we're doing them how we're doing them
what it's going to mean and and what I
really want to well as particularly it's
a good opportunity for members to
actually raise the questions which uh uh
isn't always best done by email or
questions at Council a forum like this I
think gives the best way it can be a
proper discussion around it because
obviously we want to get the best out it
I'm sure that you do as well all members
because we're all here to get the same
objectives to to get clarity around it
to be able to sort of get the service
that we want out there that works but
also take into account obviously uh
things like sustainability of this and
obviously we have taken decision to
actually reduce the use of glyphosate on
this which is obviously uh is not going
to be uh round for much longer anyway in
that sense so we have been looking at
Alternatives in there and we continue to
look at Alternatives at the same time as
well some of them but when we looked at
the Alternatives as well as the
Alternatives themselves we also have to
take account of things like uh
in its piece so in the case of it's not
just using an alternative method it's
whether that entails more carbon might
be if you're using the diesel vehicles
diesel Delivery Systems things that you
have to take it in its whole piece not
just take it as a as as a separate
system so it's a lot more to it what as
these things are that's why I have an
opportunity like this it's actually far
easier to actually have the overall
discussion simple yes no all response to
an email that's always Encompass thing
so with that I'll hand over to uh to uh
to give presentation OB if I need to
chip in with things na political stuff
like I'm more than happy to do so thank
you chair thank you
Steve thanks councelor uh just picking
up councel that said the open slide is
uh obviously focuses on what our
strategies around
sustainability
um it we we we spray the whole heart
Services right across the the the bur
and um we've reduced glyphosate by over
50% um the wee are spray with low
toxicity here beside which basically
means it's it's a contact spray and it's
not residual so it it can't be sprayed
until there's an actually show Weeds
it's very low toxicity um and that's
another thing we through the hiide is f
applied again that's what I'm saying in
the sense of unless it's actually the
weed's actually showing we can't apply
any weat killer um we've also introduced
an op and out spraying scheme this
entails residents that would not liked
for us to spray their to spray their
streets um it doesn't necessarily mean
one resident all it means a group of
residents that have agreed that we don't
spray that particular Street a good
example is is L Old Trafford they've up
to tree pits within our area they they
they they let us know prior to any
spraying and we let the contractor know
and we don't spray them three bits so
that that's like an opon out scheme
example where they they put in different
floral bedon around and treit and we
don't
sprad um the next slide this gives an
indication of as Council said said the
the the efforts to reduce glyphosate
from 2018 to 2019 you can see there was
4,400 uh liters volume and we reduced
that from 2020 to 2,200 so that's by 50%
reduce the use of
glyphosate um the weat is sprayed as I
said low toxicity there's over 800
kilometers of Highways that's giving you
some indication of the scale of the
operation that we actually do on a
year-by-year
basis H we we've chosen to continue use
of chemicals a way control weeds but we
are looking to to to use down in a
minimal as much as possible moving
forward um trafford's Council
sustainability commitment
we've completely stopped spraying using
chemicals within our parks and our
cemeteries which was heavily used uh
good 10 15 years ago we don't use any
chemicals at all in our Parks play areas
and that's been quite receptive with by
friends groups and local residents that
we're not doing that anymore um we're
looking to introduce more Wild Flower
Meadows within these areas um
encouraging the friends group to look at
areas within the parks that we can adopt
as like a medal type approach and a
different type of mowing scheme I.E we'
mow it once within a year and let
develop wild flower for within that
space these spaces look different and I
think it's important that small one line
is the the hard services on the highway
will look different some areas within
Parks will look different and it's a
very much how we we incorporate coms
around that to make people aware of what
we're attempting to
do we've not stopped completely from
using chemicals but we have reduced it
by 50% we will continue to review our
long-term strategic plans and control
invasive weeds and we'll review this
year on Year and I hope by the end of
presentation it gives some indication of
of how we we're approaching and
attempting to do
that we stop using G pH set in green
spaces and you know this is reduced the
overall glyph ofas by use by
70% and that's a huge and and we feel we
are slightly ahead of the curve in the
sense of other councils within the
greater Manchester which everybody will
have to start adopting this approach um
as the years go by and I think we're
slightly ahead of that curve in a sense
we've started this in
201920 these are some of the
Alternatives um the the the equipment to
the the left hand side is a brusher it's
like a wire brush it rotates extremely
fast and it stms off Weeds on a large
scale and the Machine to the right of
that is a small like sweeper type
machine that has like a box in front
that creates like a steam a high level
steam the reason we put these two in
this is the scale that the the industry
itself is looking at at the moment and
as councelor had said alluded to earlier
it's very difficult for us to jump in
for this type of equipment because it
mean we'd have to internalize it into
operations and the scale of the
operation is very much specialist so
although this equipment exists on the
market it's it's very small scale at the
moment but the industry is adopting to
to what's coming down the line and the
cense of legislation they are looking at
different Alternatives but this would
have to be scaled up massively when you
scale it up the cost of it moment uh
needs to change um for us to accommodate
this type of
approach these are the types of weeds
that we do get the the there's chick
weed there and there's plantain the
reason this is in there gives you know
we are responsible for spraying the
highway as a council uh we we we spray
all areas that are adopted High
Network it's the channels the wall line
the the Pavements themselves
um we usually only work on established
plants and won't stop new weeds from
growing the reason that's in there is 20
in in the early 2000s late 90s we used
what we call residual so before even
weeds were shown cils used to spray the
hard surfaces with a weed spray um and
it ca weeds at seed level but it went
into the ground and it stayed there
until the weed started the show and kill
it off that was banned um early late two
late 990s early 2000s so what that now
means is you actually have show the weed
before the spray can actually go on into
a
contact and and it's important to say we
use glyphosate to treat most weeds
glyphosate is still considered safe if
used on the manufactured instructions
and by trained Personnel we use
subcontractors to do this spray the
reason we do that it's a very
specialized operation the type of
licenses that they have are not usual
license that we have with the gr
maintenance staff they're very
specialized because of the type of
chemicals and quantities they
use
um the timelines um usually start in
miday June each year as the treatment is
only effective in dry
weather obviously the climate the
weather itself has an impact and and can
pause a spraying program
um and it can also be quite positive if
we have a quite drought typ uh type of
season it can have an impact on Weeds
themselves so it's helpful in the
program um it's estimated that any
typical year the program will take
around 12 weeks to
complete however current and more recent
weather conditions can mean that the
program can take much longer to complete
we have to put that in because we set
ourselves a goal of 12 weeks but if we
do en curse on in Clement weather it can
push it back the reason for the two
pitches is this is mostly the type of
weeds that we get They Don't Really call
structural damage they usually find a
place
within spaces that are already there
they don't create a space in a sense so
they're not structurally damaging
they're basically quite soft and
annual um treatment the weeds with two
sprays tackle weeds when they are small
and less visible we used to use two
sprays um prior about 2015 20 20134 we'd
have two sprays um but again even at
that stage we considering reducing that
because of the the the publicity around
glyphosate and the quantities that we
were actually using to carry out these
two sprays and also the impact it has if
you determine the one spray is right you
don't necessarily gain anything by
putting in a second
spray
this is just an outline of the the weed
spraying program
um it's and I'll give some indication of
why we felt logistically it was better
to start in the north than the
South
um we we we gathered the data the data
basically from each the way the wards
are made up um in in regard to density
and
residential um the operational decision
made jointly considering these elements
that we take into account it we we are
constant contact with the the operatives
that are on the ground we also share
with with our colleagues within Amy the
best way we think it should start north
or south and the reasons for this is if
if within the stord and the home free
park it's we've it it's it's quite tense
in it sense with the the guins the the
ter to and so on the reasons we start in
the north is
because if we would go from south to
North by the time we got to the north
the issues and the problems with curve
would be really immense it's that
densely housing Gins and Etc it would
slow down the Refuge collection because
you couldn't get to the to B down the
Gins and so them areas are sprayed first
and foremost quite early and that's the
reasons why we we choose to go into them
areas in the first place is is is the
intensity that's required to to move the
program forward in the South we feel we
felt you know it's less of a populated
in a sense not all areas but the
majority of some areas are quite rural
so again you know by getting to that
stage at the latter stage when we do
when we're doing one spray where we
start the program it was logistically
better to start the contractor in the
north move north to
sou and again that just gives an outline
of of of how we came to that
decision and we we we're very conscious
of the the time that it reaches that
well I'm hoping by the end of the
presentation we give you some
indications of some of the actions that
were taking for this season
coming
um we we started the procurement process
with our our contractors and um this
month we've got a meeting next week with
our contractors to agree start dates and
we'll also be introducing how we want to
approach this season uh we procure them
at the very early stages we agree start
time and we agree um certainly this
season that 12we program and in a sense
of when they start and when they
complete we want to get that and stress
that how important that is
that that start time and finish time is
a DE to and we wait to as a
performance um we've always been
challenged to procure contracts the
reasons we put this in is because of the
we reduced volume of the liters of of
glyphosate that we use some councils
within the Northwest within the greater
Manchester area haven't approached that
stage yet so to some extent we're not
really Al look the contractor for
subcontractors to be looking at in the
sense of the quantities that we're using
so it's always difficult for us to get
in early procure that contractor and get
them on board to to service the B of
traffic because we would not really
using the quantities it's not a
lucrative contract in the sense some of
the areas that they are doing but we've
managed to to do that this year and as I
said we'll meet with the contractor next
week
um looking ahead uh our team start in
both North and the South of the Bor at
the same time we've listened to to to
what members have said we've listened to
obviously residents concerns and we're
going to start two teams one North One
South now rather than moving alternating
it south north north south I think we're
just shifting the problems if we if we
adopt that approach so what we've
decided to do as is to start a team in
the north and start a team in the south
at the exactly the same time working to
the center we feel this lend itself to
different permutations and as I've
indicated in the slide we can cluster
Town centers together for example and
direct the contractors to do the town
centers Fe that we feel that's the best
approach by the moving more towards the
central obviously it also lends
ourselves to to either alter what area
that in in that particular day depending
on on on how the weather's impacted on
that particular program but both teams
starting one North One South is what we
feel is a better solution to deliver the
program more
evenly looking ahead despite the
significant media publications of
glyphosate this is around the
legislation that that is in the pipeline
and we're trying to preempt some of this
um you know it's licensed in the UK
until December
25 uh for both food production we don't
know what's going to happen after that
period of time obviously we feel this
there's going to be some form of weed
control and chemical that's that's
available on the market but again the
toxicity that will be reduced massively
um to to what we've used in previous
years
um it gives you some indication there of
some of the legislation that's out in
out at the moment but we it's it's
considered more a protos set performance
Le program that's what I indicated
earlier as we we're sitting down with
the contractor we want to make sure that
uh there's there's a regular sign off on
a weekly for nightly basis we get
feedback each each quad bike is is has a
Tracker system on it so we know where it
is any given time we get a weekly
feedback of what's being completed and
Our intention are to have more contact
with the contractor on a forly basis to
sit down and discuss
performance we also feel you know the
the the number of weed sprayed visits
would have a detrimental impact on the
environment if we increased it from one
to two to three yes it may give a
complete clear area but some of the
damages that it will do is not always
visible until later years where we
realize that you know we we've we've
created this damage in sense of
pollinators U different types of insects
wild animals Etc it will have that
impact uh and there's clear evidence
within our parks that the the the area
is changing we did have some positive
feedback from residents uh where there
are some self-seed and wild flowers
along War lines that start to appear
they not a lot at this moment stage and
we're not suggesting we don't spray
we're just suggesting at the moment
we've gone through a transition where
we've had two sprays we've gone down to
one spray we're looking at
Alternatives the the the space itself
has changed we're managing expectations
and we're taking residents on the
journey with us to to start looking at
better ways of controlling weeds
um and then quickly just on to some of
our rewi initiatives if that's okay
counselor to
to um as I said earlier we we we're
looking at Meadows within our Parks
Meadows being we we're picking sections
within our parks and agree with the
friends groups that we we reduce the
moan within these areas and we
incorporate wild flowers to start
developing a meal light type of approach
johnley Park Stanford Park are
interested um l park um
these
various other parks within the B that
are now starting to adopt this apprach
this navigation Park also is really
adopted a meadow approach it's not
neglecting grass cutting it's there will
always be a perimeter around it like a
meter or so to show that it is
maintained but it's gradually changing
the landscape to to accommodate um the
the the different wild flowers and and
and pollinators so our roundabouts to
trees estate I've just agreed with the
community within the tree state to do a
couple of roundabouts as an example to
show what they will look like with Wild
Flower I have had various conversation
with members where they've indicated
various sites within the B that would
look quite nice if we we adopted the
wildlife approach to some of the verges
um so we are looking at constantly how
how to start incorporating this into our
main
programs
and that's the presentation councelor
right thanks very much for
that yeah thank you for the report I
mean at first I was disappointed to
learn about the 50% reduction on
highways only but I do understand why
it's difficult to to phase it out I
would obviously like to see more and it
sounds like you're making good progress
in lots of things I was just curious
about um how much you take into account
the Aesthetics because you mentioned
Aesthetics in the report and and how
that kind of links and how that's
balanced with the safety because I'm
still not clear how weeds can be so
unsafe um and that's that's what I'm
curious about that because I you know I
realized that on the payments for
example is not much done to to make them
safe and it seems like there's a lot of
focus on weed removal rather than other
things the other thing I was going to
ask was um yeah it's good to see you
doing roundabouts because I really like
the ones in s for they're brilliant um
the other was going to ask about was um
the uptake of you know people opting out
was is it increasing is how's it
publicized how people know about it and
is it increasing more people doing it
are people thinking of kind of weeding
rather than just lit picking for example
yeah thank
you um firstly from from a safety
perspective it's MIP hazards and
obviously we we can if if they are
neglected weeds they they can cause
hazards on a draining way of flooding
and creating flooding Etc from a
structural perspective the weeds don't
really create structural time in the
sense unless you get likes of cell seed
and buing which are more like trees than
weeds and but that's mainly around the
safety aspect is is is a Tripp and
Hazard slippage that type of thing
really chickweed is very carpet like it
will grow off in in in a space between
Pavements and then develop carpet light
so that that's the main issue there from
aesthetic point of view um yes the
timing of the weed sprain is crucial for
us in when we actually start that and
that's where it's very much noticeable
by the lay person um you know the type
of work we do is very peripheral the
only time you notice it when we're not
doing something you don't notice it very
much when we're doing a really good job
so from a layers perspective that's the
journey that we we we're really learning
from and how we communicate around that
the sense of what we're attempted to do
just go back to Aesthetics I mean I like
weeds personally so I just wondered how
much negative response there is about
weeds because I think we should be
promoting wheat in a
way I think I think from as I said from
a lay person's perspective yes because
it's very noticeable when you when you
look at the years that I described
earlier where we've used residual and we
used two sprays all of a sudden people
are starting to notice weeds and you
know it's fair to say weeds are flowers
that we don't want at the end of the day
today that we' made the decision around
that we don't want but it's not the
majority of people you know they they
notice they start to notice this and
it's important also to to to make sure
you know the safety aspect that can
cause hazards if they're not managed in
the right
way yeah thanks CH just to pick up on
the the the first point what council
raford was saying I think is that when
you change the the way that you spray
next year so instead of starting in the
North and then going down you're going
to start from both sides basically on
you will that will that reduce the
visual impact of the weed so we won't
see the the weeds this big as we saw in
my ward this year will I've got two
other questions you want to ask that one
first and come to the other two or it's
if we could just answer that one quickly
yes that that's the that's the that's
the idea about what we're attemped to do
is to try and get that even approach
across I mean it's important to to to
stress it's a contact spray so we're
going to need some Visual and it's
managing that visual but I take your
point not to the extent of being two
three4 High um it's more getting it at
the right stage and treating it um so
yeah it's it's the take away
that yeah that's what I that's what we
tend to do start North and South look
look forward to an empty email inbox
next this next summer br
uh the second question was um was around
the way we procure the contract because
you said that we're quite low volume so
we have difficulty guessing the
contractors is there is there some um
opportunity to procure this by the star
process so we're doing it in conjunction
with the other councils part of our
procurement
te um technically
that's if you could just elaborate on
that point that I made earlier it's Tech
technically that's what we do to some
extent anyway for example a contractor
that will service traffic will naturally
be Serv than other areas with the
greater Manchester because that's how
they we their contracts so they won't
basically you won't have a contract of
coming into tra with because of what's
happening around GL State there's not a
great deal of companies that can can
provide this service now a lot of them
are either amalgamating or coming into
to one company so so the point I'm
making is is it's the procurement side
of things is not difficult I.E we're
meeting with the contract next week it's
more about monitoring them and policing
them when we do have them so they may
Drift Off to another contract a contract
like for example Bolton or
Manchester and and go and and leave us
halfway so it's more about making sure
that when they're on site we manage that
performance um we we've we've made
inroad into that last season we'll make
even more inroads this season as I said
the meeting we having next week is
clearly um explaining that to the
contractor agreeing that and making sure
at any given time we have a certain
amount of comp quad bikes on this
contract but I can't take away from
tonight the the you know the idea of
yourself saying is is the opportunities
within the grace I think that will
certainly be for for the 25 season not
this we've already as I said agreed to
move forward this season um but I think
person myself I think other councils are
interested in what we're doing and I
think they'll start reducing their
glyphosate certainly over the next
season possibly more to do with the
making the contract more attractive I'm
sure it's wear the conversation with uh
Sor I can't remember the head of the
start it Lorraine Lorraine Co sure wear
the conversation with uh to to see if
there's a possibility it's quite
surprising to hear that the contractors
just disappearing off
the I don't mean they disappear like
they just it's just the nature of if
they get in Clement weather they're
under a lot of pressure from a wider
area than just one area it's making sure
that when they agree to a certain date
that they're on this contract um and you
know that there now I'm not suggesting
it's a free fra what I am suggesting is
it needs police tightly and from a
client perspective that's my role to
make sure that I'm laying with the Amy
contract and also the contract I'm sure
you can build c ring Point financially
did things which you're not supposed to
do you know we are exploring thank you
and the final question CH is is to do
with the in the in the public spaces
like parks and cemeteries where we're
not spraying anymore how do you keep the
Pathways in those Parks clear of weeds
and say this I was Inon Cemetery just
before before um just before Christmas
and it struck me then that the the
pathways the the paid Pathways were not
any a great condition you could see the
remains of the weeds that have been
there in um over the summer so how how'
you how' you do that because there are
areas of the cemeteries and Parks which
you which you need to keep weed
free so I think the did the examples I
showed before some of the equipment that
we we we've seen especially the the
brush copper type brush cutter type
Machinery these are machine that would
explore at the moment these hand machine
so for example around the play area in
the park they will stream around there
and there is one park chassen park
that's adopted approach of around the
fence line within the play they put in
the Bas and perennial planon H so it's
not B Plant it's more softer like more
more closer to wild FL it will do show
each year so there's no there's no need
for uh spraying streamming or any that
nature it's very soft around that so
there's some of the approaches that are
been adopted by some players in the case
of Pats they would have to STM at this
moment in time which is a small machine
that the operative uses to trim off Weir
if if they get into a certain state is
that what's being done now in in the
cemeteries for example I I I particular
erston Cemetery I would say yes at the
moment I mean sales cemeteries look and
Brookland C looking really good and I'm
sure they'll they'll get on to um Amon
City and in the next few weeks so and
sometimes the time it sort of early late
March early April so again you know so
if you streammer off it has a bigger
impact rather than doing it too early
and before you know you've actually
encouraged it so by the time the
temperature increase it's away again you
know so that's it's the time of that
really yeah thank you thank
you machine when I went some of the
trials I happen in one of the parks and
it was amazing to watch it actually
reclaimed a foot pth in the par that
actually been put down by half going on
to it and they simply made thatth super
super wide
so as well it's actually really really
effective that is so that other point
about the two yeah I mean that's why
this year because the sheer amount ofet
WEA that we' actually had last year this
mpal
year it Tak 12
weeks
program signicant longer so said this is
sustainable to do this way of doing this
and therefore by start having two teams
I'm actually supplementing this with
work in town centers as well it get into
the Qui to do that so we see that there
in the future that that's the so way so
we're trying to help and always welcome
com MERS than thank you
CH we we we do have a number of people
who want to speak members so it's Count
Council if you want okay thank you chair
and just to clarify on that point Steve
and
um the it's most welcome that we're
taking a different methodology come from
the North and the South can you just
confirm whether that would be lesser uh
would be less than 12 weeks to
program um that's that's a fair question
Council that's that's our goal to to to
obviously start North Start South the
same time and as indicated in the
presentation to look at performance um
and you
know to manage that performance I mean
12 weeks is quite a three you know it's
quite a push um
so we will look to manage the only thing
I can say this evening is that we will
look to manage that performance that's
our goal to reach that 12we period um
you know with two two with one start one
start North one St and South there
should be a natural reduction of the
time that it takes for to to get from
across the B um it will certainly have
an impact in a sense of aesthetically
and also the exper because you you
you'll have spray you'll have weeds
dying off a both sides of the B at the
same time um so the answer is yes that's
our goal to to do the the 12 weeks and
we will push for that okay thank
you thanks chair I've got two questions
about weeds and one about green spaces
so I'm happy to do the green spaces one
after we finish all the weed stuff if
you
like um yeah um so just relating to my
colleague's question about the later it
is the higher they get what guarantees
do you think you could give that the
weed spraying will actually start in may
obviously subject to
weather um yeah I think um subject to
weather of the weather's you know
presentable uh we as I said earlier
we've got a meet with the contractor
next week we agree a start date um we
look to start as late as possible in May
um because you know you look at March
depending on the get snap and it's cold
up to March and then early April
temperatures start to rise Wheats will
start to show so we we'd look to get as
late into may as possible and then kick
in to get it done by the end of June
July thanks that's reassuring and second
question really really specifically I
reported a case of a a large infestation
of knotweed um almost a year ago I'm not
an expert and guessing that infestations
grow over time um is is there a solution
to this and is a one-year
delay unusual or is that
normal in in the case that you're F to
cancer is is at the back of flion garden
center and the site itself is is one of
the the problems we' got is it's it's
landlocked um it's also a fair size
infestation um just to give an example
how we manage that noxis weed in sense
of not weed we have a register where
each each time not weed is reported by a
resident or spotted by an operative or
member it goes into register and it gets
treated it could take up to three years
to treat to spray it and treat it in the
case the site that you've mentioned
there it would need a very specialist
approach to do that site um and it it is
taking time to to look at how best to
approach the site in the sense of one
the scale and two we we may feel that
spraying is not the best option it may
need some excavation we're not 100% sure
the moment but we say need Specialists
to have a look at the CED question so
there's two things really it's
landlocked and and the type and the
scale of of of the operation that
require to reduce that weed I don't know
whether my colleague shanon wants to to
add to that yeah we've been picking it
this problem up this week I appreciate
it's probably not great that it's been
since last year that we've attempted to
look at this but I think it's just been
the sheer scale of the site and
ordinarily if it was a small scale site
it would just get added to the register
and we could handle it I think this one
is something that we just need a bit of
extra investigation work on thank
you
okay thank you chair um I wonder if you
could talk a little bit about what we
could do to tackle the lack of attention
we get on spraying rights of way
passageways foot paths that don't
necessarily have a maintained
carriageway adjacent but they connect
two roads it may only be 20 feet long
but they're heavily used by local
residents and also by school children
quite a lot walking to school and they
can then be fine this time of year and
come August they're full of stinging
nettles that's is really unpleasant and
the the buggy the cart thing will just
shoot past on the
road but presumably
that's well it is adopted I've checked
because I've made them come back and
it's taken 20
emails what can we do to tackle that as
part of this holding them to account
thank you um thanks councelor um we we
we wouldn't like to
use our contractor to do that type of
work in the sense of this The Specialist
that comes in because because of the
scale that indicate in slide is over 800
kilometers of highway so we want them to
focus on that plus we've got a a program
of of of 12 weeks that we're looking to
to to complete that works so anything of
that nature we would like to internalize
because it's not the same scale as using
a quad bike you know the skill set
exists internally um and I'm sorry to
hear that you have to use 20 emails but
I think that it can be a lot more um
sharper on that in the sense talize it
means a couple of officers could go in
STM it and then spray it off for example
um you know if it's if it's just a
walkway through a right away path to
either a school or to a Sho whichever
you know it's not difficult to do so I'm
surprised is there a program though
because obviously we have a lot of those
passageways and it's just thinking you
know joined up thinking it's active
travel we want kids to walk to school
but they're going to be less inclined to
do that if it's a half a mile that way
because the path got overgrown in June
and it's not been done and it's that
it's that kind of thing so is there a
program or is it going to rely again on
like individual board members saying oh
I've got a path here and she's got a
path there is is there a program for it
I take I take your point C at the moment
yes it's reactive and I won't deny that
it's not reactive can we make it more
proactive then we'll say it take away
from this evening and and look into
that coun
cin thanks and thanks John for the
presentation um I had a few questions um
can we do things that make it less
likely that weeds will grow so um for
example the problems we know we have
sometimes collecting Leaf litter or
block drains are they creating
environments where weeds are likely to
grow so if we put in more effort to
clearing those problems are we likely to
get less weeds and then need less
glyphosate that that's one question um I
had another one about the change from
going north south to isn't isn't the
middle going to become the new South
won't the places in the middle have the
same delay that places in the South have
had or have I missed something there um
I was um yeah glad to see this reduction
following a a green party motion some
years back um can I confirm also that
we're still doing no more no more may I
think the council decided to do that
some years ago it wasn't mentioned here
so I want to check was still happening
um and finally are we doing any analysis
of the biodiversity impacts of on of our
changes so like you said the place are
interested in in copying so are we
measuring anything that we can share
thanks thanks coun um first off um to
your first question yes I mean it's
simplistic if if you if you remove every
piece of the tries it leavs better
ground it leavs less ground for for a
weed to seed um but this this the scale
of that um they will always find a place
whether it's a not got a cranny dou
always so you kind of it does help to to
stay on top of detrus and it's the
simple answer to
that um in regards
of um the second question
um is in the middle of the new South
yeah well I mean that's that that is a I
mean we're starting North and South
because we feel that's the best way of
approaching things but because you've
got two teams on the contract at the
same time as I said earlier it it can
lend itself to different permutations
one of them permutations could be well
we'll cluster the town centers and we'll
direct them teams to do the town centers
for example so there are any areas where
we feel are slightly getting away we can
then do a different pentation and put a
team into the South into the center if
if if it needed that but we feel by both
teams working the way they're working it
they will get more to that Center than
the what they've been in the past if if
that makes sense but we will monitor I
think it's a fair point and we will
monitor
closely um and your last question sorry
Council uh just confirming no more may
is still going on and then asking about
any analysis of the impacts of the
change the no more may we we are
exploring and again it is changing
people's mind set towards not cutting
grass in the month of May we won't do
that on a large volume scale because it
could create issues and problems that we
we're not able to manage we will do it
in certain areas where we feel it'll be
more receptive uh in line with some of
the Wild Flower areas that we've created
um or you know certain areas where we're
looking to explore like some of the
sites that yourself mentioned of doing
you know a wild flower scheme and so yes
to that on an analys perspective we feel
it's slightly early at the moment we're
starting to get data together now to
sort of look at how how it is operating
the impact it is having and obviously
you know the evening is a big Mass step
forward to answering that question in
the sense of you know appearing to
before scrutiny this evening and we're
more focused on our weed Spain program
but it's given us an opportunity to be
transparent and share with people what
we're actually attempting to do so once
we've gathered all that together and I'm
sure we'll be a position maybe this time
of year to start sharing of of the
impact that we've
had thanks sure um two just two points
like make first of
all I've learned something from this
presentation I know now exactly what I'm
doing wrong with my multiple um
applications of glyphosphate and Flame
to uh keep the side access to my house
clear um one thing I do find is deep
rooted weeds mentioned the the weeds
just appear on the top the B of my life
but things like Dand light with the long
tubers which appear to be causing
damage
um do they create a major problem in our
public spaces as they're threatening to
do in someone on private
spaces thanks Council feedback um teles
in themselves is an unusual one you
either love them or you hate them I mean
sometimes when we have a lot of grass
veres that are covered in D the lines we
usually get you know good feedback
because to see that type of flaw play on
that scale is huge can they can they
cause damage they I think any we can if
if totally neglected year on year can
cause damage and but I wouldn't see
dandel Lions creating huge structural
damage uh and certainly not not on to
the highway itself um
they they are quite an evasive weed in
the sense of the way the seed they seed
quite quickly and they disperse the
seeds onto the wind and they can spread
quite widely
but they can also create a nice flal
display you know so it is in a way
getting that right balance but I don't
see them doing any structural damage on
the highway in that sense
no
okay
um thank you CH just a couple of
comments if you allow me um councilor
Axford thank you for your feedback about
Rew Wilding of roundabouts um like you I
think they look fantastic I think in
particular we've got a couple up in
traffic Park as you're approaching uh
traffic key side and every time we get
to the summer months I think they look
really beautiful with the trees in
Blossom the grasses at sort of knee
height and then all the wildf flow and I
very much um welcome be is trying to
take more of that approach across the B
um like you I'm also a fan of weeds I
understand the argument around
Aesthetics but you know nature isn't it
it's not always tidy and uniform
sometimes it is a little bit messy a
little bit scruffy um councel fast thank
you also for your um defensive active
travel earlier um always very welcome um
CH I'm conscious that we focus mainly on
weed spring this evening but I did also
just want to acknowledge Billy that
there's a wider body of work that's
being undertaken by the council um I say
this as councelor at and I have just
come from the one traffic partnership
board's quarterly meeting um which we
did have a bit of discussion around the
authorities work to progress a green
spaces strategy and personally I think a
more robust and strategic approach to
the council's management of our green
spaces is something that is long overdue
really um so I do welcome the work that
Sharon and her team have been engaging
in to draw up the strategy and hopefully
that document can expand and formalize
some more information about activities
such as re Wilding and our efforts to
enhance biodiversity in our green spaces
um certainly ch I think that the
feedback of the scrutiny committee would
be welcome as the strategy is finalized
finalized and is approaching adoption um
it's for the committee to determine its
own uh workload but it may be that um
scrutiny committee want to engage in a
bit of pricision scrutiny um around the
strategy before it's sent to the
executive approval just a suggestion
thank you
chair
perfect
timing Aiden I appreciate that um
specifically on green spaces and I just
want to kind of explore a conversation
around the the the old William
ride
um I I'm aware of um suggestions and
investigations for things such as
Wetlands development a Memorial Forest
potential site for a park run and other
options all of which are brilliant in
terms of potential to increase usage of
Park to generate mental health physical
health and biodiversity
benefits particularly when you look at
the the weather that we've recently had
and and ongoing weather patterns I think
all of these depend on improving access
to that site through entry points and
crucially through Pathways across and
around the site uh without these this is
a fantastic asset that is either
inaccessible or underutilized for much
of the year because it's a quagmire um
so I guess my questions are what can be
done to a accelerate planning for adding
Pathways and B attract funding to
support this
thanks
any response with regard to
that I think we'll have to take that one
away to be perfectly honest I know that
there are some plans to plans to to do
that but we can we'll we'll relay those
relay that that that question back to
back to um strategic both so sorry
you're saying there are plans
potentially to put some Pathways in I
know there are plans there plans there
are some plans in their embre onics but
I'm the wrong person to person to t you
for that so we'll we'll we'll pull that
back to um strategic growth and get ad
to give you a
response when we do a report back um
we'll CH just before you finish on it as
well I just I did forget to add before
just very very quickly say Obviously at
the end of each uh we Spain season it is
always reviewed in that sense isn't the
case of like what we're taking forward
now is going to be the end all and be or
at the end of each season Once it's done
if we encounter problems they will be
reviewed again so those all comments
always welcome from members and feedback
from them it helps to actually enhance
the service thank you um only a tiny
little bit from myself um was just in
response to a couple of uh a couple of
the questions that questions that were
there um it is always a compromise um
weed spray I think one of the key one of
the key Parts was when you start um
we're trying to change and do something
a little bit different with a different
contractor um we're trying to make sure
that uh make sure that we've got a
little bit more control over that start
date a little bit more control over over
uh the different options that are
available to us and actually start off
in different different um different
parts I think the comments around the
around the guinel and the and and
actually the active travel bit was uh
was was well made in terms of the
biodiversity measurement um James is
going to give a give give a presentation
a little bit later is our new climate um
uh climate manager so so one of the
things that he's already given
presentations about to uh to ourselves
is about how we how we do measure
biodiversity going forward obviously
this uh the the recommendations in this
uh will be will be subject to that
measurement so so we're at an early
stage but what we what we will do is is
make sure that they uh that we're we're
all tied together to make sure that
actually gets
done is there any other
comments yeah Jill I just wanted to we
speak up about um Kings Way Park seems
we just brought will row I mean it just
seems it's just a you know ideal site
for rewinding I know there's a master
plan so I just wanted to wonder what was
going on with it thank
you did anybody have an answer to that a
specific part yeah we have to take that
away and see what the plans are for that
so yeah there's a long list of all the
parks that I know that our strategic
planning teams are looking
at
one of the things that I think is really
important is those
contracts uh because if contractors sign
up to do a job and then they uh leave to
do another job it's it's like Builders
isn't
it um so we but we we we should tie that
down um you know of a contract and and
not let them get away with it quite
eff I think in furnace in terms of
contractors attempting to leave site I
think it's normally a case that there
may be times when it's raining really
heavily here but it's not on another
contract where they've probably got time
to go back to so I think that would be
the only time we would expect them to
even attempt to leave our sites um
because if they can't spray here at
least they could spray somewhere else so
I think that's within their gift to do
that but you're quite right with the
pinning them down on the start date is
the key
thing um right well thanks very much for
the presentations and uh answering the
questions it's much
appreciated that you've come along uh
tonight um and we will you know um
discuss this ourselves and make some you
know
recommendations uh or comments about
what we've heard um yeah so that that
concludes that uh part and the next part
uh is the
allotments um so I don't
know CH chair have question just we had
agreed as a screening committee that we
weren't doing presentations that we were
taking the presentations as r so that we
could use this time for you know to make
good use and where we've brought loads
of officers here and I really appreciate
that they have given presentations and
perhaps if you've already prepared to
give presentations but we did agree that
as a
committee we did but I think it it was
interesting to hear you know some more
of the context that was not in the
report so have we abandoned that
agreement no we not abandoned it um but
we
so no we haven't aband we're going to
continue to have reports so we're going
to continue to not have
reports right who who who oh right than
thank okay thank you chair um I don't
have a presentation um but I um was
going to just s talk through a few
points from the report if that's helpful
or we can go straight to questions I'm
in your
hands yeah just made made comment okay
thank you um so just to introduce myself
I'm James Harris I'm the head of climate
change and sustainability in the new um
climate change and sustainability
service in place directorate in the
council um and allotments sits within
our service
area um obviously the importance of
allotments is that it links across to
all three of our corporate priorities um
in terms of reducing Health inequalities
links to climate change and green spaces
and
biodiversity um and supporting people
out of poverty um we recognize it's a
really crucial service in terms of
supporting Community cohesion reducing
loneliness and and it's a service a lot
of people rely
on um so we have a full-time officer um
who sat with me here Bob gowell working
on the allotment service um and that is
an increase from previously where we had
a part-time officer working on this so
that's since September of last year so
that's kind of obviously very welcome
we've got some extra resource gives us
the opportunity to um really sort of
take stock and think about things a bit
more uh strategically and think about
what our priorities are um so I'll just
talk through some of those main main
points there so um in the report we talk
about a few of the challenges that we
face um in the alignment service and
then also some of the opportunities um
one of the main challenges is around
costs so the um the rental uh fee has um
is 104 it's less for half plots and
quarter plots and there's discount for
people over 60 um that hasn't changed
for I think since 2015 but obviously
costs have continued to increase over
that time so that's uh one of the big
challenges and um the allotment service
is entirely funded through the revenues
that are raised um through the allotment
service U and that covers a whole range
of different um areas of Maintenance and
uh that we have to sort of carry out so
that's one of the really big challenges
um and you know we a a prioritization
matrix to try and decide where to
prioritize our work um but that has
become increasingly difficult over time
um there are some challenges around
climate change and the impacts that's
having so we're seeing uh flooding in
some allotment sites and that's been a
challenge um and also conversely in
summer months we're seeing more extreme
heat and and the impact that has on uh
food cultivation can be quite
severe and then another challenge is
around waiting lists so the waiting list
is currently about
540 um that's not as long as some other
districts but obviously you know we're
keen to look at what we can do to try
and uh reduce that um to sort of
maximize people's uh chances to access
this access
allotments um but then as I said we're
kind of keen to um try and take a
proactive um rather than reactive
approach and think about this a bit more
strategically um so one the things we'll
be doing over the coming year is
developing an allotment
strategy um and that's really an
opportunity to review everything that
we're doing and and consult with um uh
tenants and and committees on allotments
and to try and get people's views about
how we can run the service better um
we're going to look at communications
and sort of see uh throughout this year
if we can build allotments into our
Communications plans more and and
promote what we do through the allotment
service
um we are going to look at what we uh
can do around the website there is
information on our website about
allotments but there is scope for
improving that information for providing
more resources online uh forms that
people can access for
example um we're also going to be
reviewing our internal processes so um
seeing if we can uh increase
efficiencies or we can optimize some of
the work that we do um uh and sort of
improve some of these internal um
processes that we carry
out um and then I think there's also an
opportunity around sort of networking
and training this is one that we're
really Keen to look at um there are
different committees and individuals um
on the allotments who have lots of
different unique um and varied skills
we're keen to sort of try and encourage
sort of peer-to-peer exchange between
different alotment sites and to try and
uh encourage capacity building and
learning that way and training and
support
um and as part of the process of
developing the strategy we'll try and
think about what some of these training
requirements are and how we can best
support
that um we're also Keen to S see what we
can do around um promoting an increase
in self-managed allotment sites so some
of the allotments are self-managed some
are run uh managed by volunteer
committees and others are managed by the
council tells um some of the
self-managed uh leas sites are you know
well I mean they're all really really
well looked after um I think we're quite
Keen to see if there's scope for
encouraging more allotments to become
self-managed and to sort of um help
support them in that
Journey um we're keen to look at funding
so I've said that you know cost is a
increasing pressure um and we're keen to
as part of the development of the
allotment strategy to um really carry
out a thorough review of all possible
funding sources to see if there are
other funding opportunities that we can
take advantage of um and then um I think
the committee wanted to sort of talk a
bit about food cultivation as well um
outside of allotments there's a lot of
work going on across Trafford supported
by the likes of uh tcv and Trafford
Community Collective around food growing
uh Community Food growing and I think
we're quite Keen to tap into that and to
see if we can do things to help promote
that and that could be quite a useful
resource for you know people that might
be on the waiting list but in the
meantime want to get involved in uh
Community Food grow projects so we're
going to see if there's more we can do
to link up with some of those
initiatives and to help support and
promote
those so I'll leave it at that for now
just give a quick overview some some of
the main challenges and
issues thank you
chair so thanks so just think a couple
of questions one specific one more
General I'll start general um there
self-funding so we fund the service
through the rent is there any scope to
look at expanding sites or to look at
um Council own plots of land that could
be turned into another allotment site
because for each site itself you know
that that that funds the service so okay
there's more to maintain but you balance
that in that would obviously tackle the
waiting list are we going to open any
new sites in sure secondly um my patch
Grove Lane I've been in touch with your
yourself there Bob um I think the report
from memory I have done my reading but
my memory is not as good about four
unviable sites so I presume they're not
rented out but yet there are ones with
rent with owners renting out but they
are underwater so you know we've also
got people who are actually paying but
you know it's going to be completely
rotten isn't it whatever they're growing
there it's underwater it's a real
challenge to tackle that um there's all
sorts of work going on nearby with with
underground CTS and things in the
meantime is there anything we can do
some of the the red allotment holders
have talked about raised beds or
something to at least give some use of
their plot rather than just it's
underwater for six months a year and
it's complete waste and we we've talked
briefly about that and I wonder if you
could sort of expand on that and say you
know how do we tackle sites that are
that are flooded and can we have some
new sites yeah okay um so on the first
point about sort of increasing uh
provision I mean there aren't any plans
to do so at the moment um obviously it's
quite a significant upun investment um
and the kind of current economic climate
would probably make that quite
challenging I'd say um I think what we
would be doing is looking to uh explore
the scope for promoting local growing
groups as I was saying before um as an
opportunity to get people involved in
community growing initiatives um and
using that as a way of sort of almost
effectively tackling the the waiting
lists um the in terms of council land I
mean that's something I'm sure we can
take away um you know as part of our the
development of our strategy alment
strategy we want to be Consulting quite
widely in that and we'll be Consulting
with members and with allotment holders
and and committees um so that's maybe
something we can look at as part of the
strategy
development um in terms of flooding yet
it is a real issue I know that in a few
areas we have actually decommissioned
some of the plots because they are
so frequently underwater so that people
weren't um paying rent for very little
return um um again this will be part of
the strategy to look at how we can best
deal with this I know that we work with
Amy and they have some training
Engineers who look at this as well so
we'll be working with them quite closely
on it um raised beds I guess could be
could be something that could also be
considered as well as part of that
strategy
yeah yeah specifically with with with
that alotment it's suppos trouble the
raise that they then will degrade over
time but yeah it's it's um something
I've actually considered importing some
sort of top soil as
like fixing that specific
allotment councelor Jones did you
oh I'm going down the road councelor
winstanley
[Music]
thanks for the running through the at
least the early stages of the strategy
what what I what I saw what you
presented looks um definitely moving the
right direction the bit I'd like to talk
well there there several questions but
the bit I'd like to talk about a little
bit further is how you will build
networks between different um different
alotment sites particularly how you will
get tenants involved in those because um
as we as we know all voluntary
organizations naturally tend towards
oligarchy and that's absolutely true of
allotment committees so how will you
involve tenants in that which I think is
really really
important um the second question is
around self-managed allotments is at
allotment sites how much control does
Trafford then have uh or how much input
would traffic have directly with the
tenants on self Manning side so for
example if somebody had an issue with
the with the committee would traffic get
involved in that and thirdly is a
question around accessibility on on my
own allotment side the committee there
of which I'm not part so I can't take
credit for this did an awful lot of work
in making one of the sites disabled
friendly and very very disabled friend
they went off and raise a fortune to do
this and built it and built it on the
site themselves
is there an element in the strategy to
do with that encouraging the uh the
inclusivity element of the uh of the
elment service as part of your plan okay
thank you thank you um so I mean how how
are we going to involve the tenants in
that networking is not something we've
really started working through yet so I
think we we will take that away and have
a think about it um I think you know we
are Keen obviously you know where we can
where there are committees we will work
with committees but we do also want to
reach out to tenants um directly as well
just to make sure that you know people
aren't being excluded from any
Communications um it's really you'll
find people who aren't Keen to be
involved in the committee it's a lot of
work to be involved in the committee but
we'll be very keen to take part in maybe
a uh conversation and it's it's the
mechanics of that really do you even
have the contact details the members of
the individual tenants that was uh a
question I'm not sure that you do have
those we do yeah think I think we don't
we don't have all the emails which is
what we're trying to work on so we can
just communicate a lot
quicker and and this kind of comes back
to sort of trying to just um update our
internal processes as well you know we
have a database with contacts but we
don't always have the emails we often
have to send things hard copy you know
there's a lot of chart scope for
improving that I think and and um you
know making it easier to to reach out to
people
individually um self-managed allotments
how much I mean they are as as the name
suggests you know they're pretty
self-sufficient um and we then tend not
to have that much involvement um in
things I mean I guess if there was a
particular dispute then we would get
involved um and then that and you know
we can have that conversation with the
uh uh with the individual and with the
uh the group that's running
it um and accessibility yeah I think
that's a really good point I mean that's
not something we flagged up specifically
in this report but I think it is a
really key aspect that we want this to
be accessible um you know we've also
sort of thought as well had discussions
internally about just making them more
accessible generally that you know
allotments are often closed off and you
can sort of live near them and never
never go inside them but I think just
trying to kind of open them up a bit
more now and again and seeing if there
are opportunities to you know run events
and open the doors so that people can
come in and and and see the see how
they're see what they're like and and
sort of understand more about food
growing and that sort of thing we're
quite Keen to do that but yeah I mean
accessibility in that sense of as well
in terms of um people in wheelchairs and
disabilities is definitely going to be a
key
issue really interesting how this
develops I think is so far really
impressed with the work You' done so far
I thank you CH if I if I could I mean if
we are looking to draft any strategies
moving forward I think an equality
impact assessment would naturally form
part of that process so considerations
around disability and access would
obviously um be incorporated at that
stage Council but certainly if you've
got examples of best practice from your
l i very happy if You' like to share
those with us directly um and we can
look to try and identify the sort of
stuff you talking about thank
you thanks chair and um thanks it was
really helpful um James at the start of
your comments to identify what the key
challenges are so I can ask two
questions related to your challenge
themes uh the first around waiting lists
so are there protocols to Cease the teny
for a tenant who does not use or
maintain that plot acceptably and
there's an opportunity to tighten those
to encourage release of plots to Eagle
waiters um yes there are um so there are
kind of various um stages that we can go
through um in terms of um sort of
flagging concerns right through to a
notice to quit ultimately um I mean in
terms of how we use those protocols I'd
say each case is quite different and and
sort of needs quite a certain amount of
you know kind of an open-minded attitude
and and and a kind of good listening ear
because you know sometimes you can hear
about a particular issue and you sort of
think oh that sounds like a kind of cut
and dry example of where someone should
be potentially um asked to leave but
then you kind of dig a bit deeper and
you understand there are mitigating
circumstances and things so we try and
be fair we try and be quite open and
listen to some of the concerns but yeah
there's a sort of set sort of
three-stage process we can go through in
terms of issuing letter is to register
these concerns and ultimately like I say
a notice to
quit thank you and I'll proceed my
second question by saying I think the
allotments culture and spread and what
the work a lot of our residents do is
absolutely fantastic and really great uh
but we are facing the most acute
financial and budget pressures um any of
us have experienced and think just
reading in um the LGA report today the
majority of leaders of councils in
England are not completely confident
they'll be able to fulfill their
strategy to expend obligations in the
coming Financial year so in that context
um a question around viab viability uh
are their plans to review the rents that
you say have been on change for nine
years and also are the plans either to
end the 50% discount for 60 plus year
olds or change the age for the discount
to state pension age
um which would evidently increase
Revenue so I mean there are no specific
plans at the moment um in internally um
we will need to review them at some
point because it is becoming
increasingly difficult with the way that
costs have been increasing to maintain
um that that rental um annular rental
amount um so um you know I think there
will need to be consideration of that
but I mean we've not yet looked at what
that might look like and um whether it
would involve changing the um the uh age
limit for the discount or anything like
that
councelor um yeah a lot of my questions
already been asked I particularly think
that might be important to increase the
plot rental um and I'm really excited
about the community growing groups and
was really positive about that and I
like the idea of like people sharing
equipment as well allotments and
networking with each other and looking
at the scope of healthy eating organic
food thing um so I think everything else
is been
covered anything else thank
you right
councelor thanks um yeah a few questions
H in the intro it talks about supporting
people out of poverty which is obviously
one of the great benefits of growing
your own food I'm just wondering how
effectively we're actually doing that so
do we have demographic stats or if you
are going to an equality impact
assessment do we know are these actually
mostly middle class people who have this
as a hobby or are we actually helping
people who really can't afford it and
and in line with that I was wondering is
the cost of 104 paid in one set amount
or is can that be spread across the year
because obviously that will be a
deterrent so that's one question um
secondly I know some of the allotments
in recent years have had worries about
their lease renewals and rumors about
the land being sold off and things like
that can we come confirm that none of
our current allotments are under any
sort of threat and um are there kind of
robust plans in place to give people
good long plan um good long heads up
when leases are are to be renewed um and
finally um just following up on what
others have said about expansion is
there room for Less formal kind of
community growing projects um in
stretford near the library there used to
be Incredible Edible growing vegetables
on on those planters that are now gone
um are things like that we can do that
don't have a huge cost to the council um
and that work a bit like maybe the
friends of the park that basically
residents are are making use of some of
our green spaces perhaps even saving the
council from some maintenance um costs
thanks okay thank you so on the first
point was about sort of stats on
demographics I mean I don't think we
have that sort of linked to the um
allotments um and I think you know what
we can do is we can use uh traffic data
lab to try and understand some of that
better I think you know as again as part
of the strategy I don't want to put
everything on the strategy but as part
of that process I think we'd very much
like to do that kind of analysis if the
data is available to understand some of
those questions um the um 104 pounds and
I think is it paid all in one go is yeah
um but yes that's just a single annual
amount um I'm struggling to read my own
writing oh lease renewals oh s land
being sold off I mean I don't I don't
know of any plans I'm not aware of any
um we can you know definitely sort of as
part of the strategy try and commit to
giving as much notice to people as
possible but I mean we'd have to talk
that through with other bits of the
council to understand that process more
and how much time we can sort of
reasonably give people um and then final
Point yes I mean in terms of more scope
for Less formal Community growing groups
I think that is something we definitely
want to look at um I don't know what the
scope is there for the council sort of
directly supporting that but I think we
to consider what we can do to kind of
promote that and to try and help link up
some of these groups and give them more
visibility Council thank you uh just a
couple of points one that uh
it's I know because it's such a big
waiting list if you were to Pro promote
the the allotments in any way you you'd
obiously increase it and you won't have
the capacity to be able to accommodate
them that's one point uh but obviously
you've got to try stke the violance to
keep that interest and get more people
looking and taking an interest and the
other important thing I think we're
perhaps missing is the the other end of
the age group where we need the younger
people to take a bit more interest how
to promote them because obviously with
uh the Obesity situation we've got one
in one in three one in four kids you
know Bas and having uh getting the
education in terms of organic growing
and healthy eating it probably feeds
into that health and well-being agenda
so I think that would be an important
aspect to put
it the the strategy what you
think okay I think you ra a really valid
point um Council and I think it speaks
also to the point that Council cogins
was making I think what will be
important as we look to try and
formalize the first dra the strategies
that we made sure that council's public
health team are also meaningfully
involved in drawing up the strategy and
certainly that's something we can commit
to this evening thank
you yeah thank you chair yeah just on
points that Council of cogging with aing
uh I'm certainly they much aware of like
fenter Parks groups are developing uh
growing food in their in their park well
not their parks in our Parks people's
Parks residents Parks absolutely and
we've certainly be suppored of that and
I aware of of course obviously in the
stford In Bloom group had some that but
of course the can't want because the
Redevelopment found Kings Way and my
understanding is that the all those
Planters will be coming back once the
work is completed so so I've no doubt
that we'll see that in future uh I don't
know if like Al Bloom group do something
similar I imagine they probably do think
certainly be supportive they did
something putting Planters in and
helpself the food I think that's
certainly something that we all welcome
there and certainly if any friends group
wants to do that it's quite welcome I
know as a councilor I
discussed what other options are a
couple of messages from Members about
alternatives to that what was touched on
earlier want to sort look at maybe going
something in like a little uh I know
like during the pandemic finish there
was a couple of me groups came forward
who'd formed during covid and they want
to take over maintenance of La a piece
of AA near near them which the count
maintained so so that can be looked at
we haven't got anything formal there
nothing formal about it we probably have
the resources drop a massive maps and
plans like some have but if res get
interested in doing something little
plot of land at the council loan
something like that that I'm sure were
quite well they're quite
to come and talk to us I'm happy to
discuss that with them and see how we
can best get get them some sort of
control over that land there so certain
supports of this and growing food
particularly is very important going
forward obviously as well as cost of
living crises obviously it gets people
it gets into involved in doing things
actually more healthy options as well so
think we're very supportive of all those
sort of measures so I've sort of Welcome
all those sorts of things obviously a
lot sit very formalized if people do
something on their own street it's less
formalized but I think they're certainly
all welcome I think thank thank
you just a very small bit to add on to
add on for that obviously the work
that's going to take place as part of
the Green Space strategy um it is fairly
emonic at the moment but trying together
all the all the elements elements of
that they certainly going to be elements
of to the Friends of parks and so on
that we can we can put in Our intention
at least to to kind of to kind of move
some of those some of those suggestions
that have been made made forward within
that when we tie that strategy
together
okay is there any other uh questions
no okay well well thanks thanks very
much
yeah one thing I I did reading the
report was um schools going uh to to
allotments and I think that's really
good um you know to uh because you know
many children don't have Gardens and and
so on so I think more that we can do uh
with that U I think the better
but I think you know obviously going to
be building a strategy aren't you so uh
we we'll we'll wait for that uh and uh
you know we we'll put some comments back
to you uh as well which has come out of
this
meeting okay but thank thank you uh very
much indeed uh for for your attendance
and the work that you are doing um and
thanks to you know thanks to the
officers and thanks to the executive
members
um you're able to leave now if you
want unless you want to stay to the
end
two tpes of
carrots no was for Rich so I didn't
know
[Music]
always thank you
right we'll can move on well just in in
terms of what we've we've heard um we we
will put a report together and
circulate circulated to all all the
scrutiny
members on what we've just heard and
yeah yeah and you know what what we
would like to see um which you know
you've gone through the questions you
you've got answers and I think some some
issues uh we we would probably want to
emphasize in terms of what might be in
the um the plans that they've got so um
but it at a starting
point
Harry has been jotting it down uh dting
everything down and we we we can
circulate that and uh if you want to
comment on on that report you want to
say anything how yeah just a quick one
um whether whether that will go as a
report or not I'm not sure but we can
definitely definitely provide all the
feedback from the minutes um that you've
given just so we can get an answer to
those things moving forward especially
with that um the allotments strategy we
can definitely have that brought to us
in the future but obviously we'll let
them work through it in the time yeah
that's that's
fine okay uh item seven uh it's a budget
scrutiny report and we um unfortunately
we not got it here um it has been sent
to
officers and the report as no we've got
we've got the budget scrutiny report
sorry oh no I'm talking about the wrong
one now yeah so yeah sorry we have got
the budget uh scrutin report
it will see um the old traffic task and
finish Group which we haven't got the
report and we'll come on to that but
yeah the you you've got that uh budget
report um and are there any comments
around
that if everybody's happy with it to go
uh to the
executive um we'll do that yeah okay um
item eight um is a task and finish group
events um of Manchester United and and
so on um yeah the LA Lawrence was a
chair of um this task and finish group
is is away um
so um he wanted it to
go as an interim report uh to the
executive um and um and that inim
report um has he he he's actually you
know completed that uh
and uh we wanted to bring it here
tonight but it was it's with the
officers who
um proof reading and what they actually
do in terms of these reports because it
you know obviously it will become
a um a a public document and so they
always proof read it and make sure that
there's nothing that's uh um illegal
that you put in or whatever um but we
haven't got it back so um we we we we
hope to uh be able
to um provide it tomorrow if we possibly
can uh for your approval or otherwise
I'll make comments um but we probably
need for you to do that in a couple of
days you know so hopefully we can get it
out
tomorrow and if you
could um
you know give your thoughts about it if
you so wish to or give your okays or not
okays then uh hopefully you could do
that by uh the end of
Thursday so we' got two two
days so um
yeah thanks um I look forward to to
reading that um one for us uh just at
the moment and I may have a be in my
Bonnet about this uh but having attended
pretty much all of those task and finish
meetings and asked this question of
senior officials at Manchester United on
more than one occasion and getting a
non-specific not really an answer answer
each time I wonder can we force a yes no
answer out of them as part of this
process so with a rise smile I note that
a quarter of the ownership is Now with
uh the guy who actually owns inos Gren
grenadiers the best cycling team in the
world some might say Eric tenh har is a
keen cyclist and Dave brailford is now
gonna be developing performance
enhancement having made Britain a global
leader in in cycling performance and yet
if you ride a bike to Manchester
United the experien is borderline
hostile as opposed to to welcoming so
the question I've put to to mfc's um
senior managers on more than one
occasion is can you change your ambition
so that there are perhaps
750 accessible safe cycling parking
places at Manchester United as part of
your thoughts and plans for the future
um there would be
evident PR and reputational benefits for
them from this they go from being
probably the worst provider in the
Premier League to providing more safe
secure space than all the rest of the
Premiership GRS combined um but also
there is a real if we're going to try
and tackle some of the problems
generated by the traffic then active
travel if encouraged I personally
believe would grow it's just such a
hideous Prospect at the moment that
nobody would do it more than once so as
part of this can we force a yes no
answer to to
that
Force
yeah I'm I'm having problem talking yeah
yeah um yeah uh I don't think we can
force them I supp yes and no but uh
usually you know you have something in
between yes and no uh so so uh but what
what we can do is is put it in the
report I can't remember whether it was
item I know that we we we've all raised
that uh we with with man united and
we've not got uh you know a complete
answer to it um and I think they've done
a few bits and pieces but nothing like
the 700 which we you know we we've kind
of been asking that the provision is
still the tiny provision is still during
which no cyclist would ever Park
I think we've actually said that haven't
we on few occasions yeah Harry anything
in this interim report yes so I just
pulled the report on now there is there
is um referenc in some of the
recommendations to to increasing uh so
so one of them is to look at the option
to run a secure bike storage trial with
Manchester United to see if this
increases cycle into matches um so there
is
a reference of it currently in the
recommendation we can um we may be able
to look at it um I know that it's also
part of the recommendations to um
classify certain roads as as as as red
routes around the ground which again I
think from the information in the report
wants to suggest that this will
hopefully increase then cycling around I
I I think the turn around to to talk to
Manchester United now um and sort of get
a yes and answer as the chair said would
be quite difficult um just due to the
sort of time frames the report I
think I think um the that obviously the
reported hour report and it goes to the
executive it doesn't go to Manchester
United um I mean they they will have Sid
of it and they might be able to make
comments but you know what we would be
doing is recommending to the executive
that we put pressure on man united to
and and I think we could specify because
we have specified before um that we
would like to see if it's in the draft
report I'm happy to add suggested
additional yeah content or what things
yeah yes so when there report comes
through just provide the feedback on it
and we can yeah you know that goes for
for all of us that we can provide um you
know if it's something that you'd want
to see in that
report um okay so with that uh oh yeah
go whil I can
see the attraction of putting pressure
on United to proove the
C for an organization that needs a new
stadium a new manager a new team
where is people arriving on their bikes
going to sit on their priority list I
fully appreciate what you're trying to
do on there but I just I probably W
against get too
Enthusiast because as far as
United thanks the entire purpose of the
task and finish group isn't to improve
Manchester United or the experience of
Manchester United it's to improve the
impact on the residents who have to put
up with the consequences of them and
therefore your your comment there could
apply to any of it why would there be
bothered improving extra Trams bus
feries back into town uh Road management
information systems there's no
performance reason for them to do
anything it's part of being a good
neighbor and a partner with the
council
yeah
yeah clearly um you know we have had
discussions with
officials and uh I think they recognize
that there is some need for uh having
some provision to park you know the
cycles and I I think what we need to do
is to put pressure on them and you know
it's not our business around who's the
manager and who which players have' got
and all that but
well yeah but but but we you know we we
we discuss these issues with the
community side of man united um not not
the um Who oversee the finances and all
of that um so
anyway as far as I'm concerned we we we
we can we we we can put that in because
we have raised it uh on a number of
occasions Council about
thank you chair um I mean I'm not
familiar with what the report has to say
or background to it because I've not
been in the meetings or anything but it
does seem a bit strange you know that
whenever planning applications come in
from
development we seem to be very strict
and stringent on making sure that there
cycling racks and things available uh
for those kind of developments and uh it
just seems a little bit surprising you
know that I mean I'm I'm not say we're
familiar with what the that the interim
report was says but I would think that
hopefully it would it should be
encouraging from them to say that they
they're applying some kind of uh uh
provision the problem
is the problem is that they don't have
any
plans so so we we we're working without
any plans if they put a planning
application into EXT the ground or new
uh sorry the the uh Stadium
itself um then we would have a lot of
leeway quite frankly and that's what
we're waiting for um but in the
meantime uh you know the they have not
put any plans forward for their Stadium
as yet um but we expect that they will
do it at some point um so anyway I think
for for this report it's an interim
report and
um we we we have raised it with them and
it should be in that interim report and
it is in the interim report but it
hasn't specified the
numbers
okay so look out for for that
report
yeah look look look out for that report
tomorrow and make your comments as you
wish and if you don't want to make any
comments that's fine as well but we'll
try and present
it I'll send it to the executive by
Friday uh because I think the meeting's
on Monday isn't it yeah it's it's a week
on under the executive the hope is to
get it to that meeting week before Clos
a play Thursday or early Friday morning
be brilliant that's okay
yeah
okay right we'll uh we'll move on to
item nine which is the work program
which is there before you is there any
comments anybody wants to make before we
go home yeah
Jill um I don't think there
on no I was just going to ask about
having an update on what's happening
with the Travelers um
because we haven't had one for ages the
other thing I'm aware of I have
contacted you about um lq more issues of
mold as well so I wondered what we were
doing about
that yeah I mean we in in in the reports
Travelers trial and consultation of
temporary stopping area underway
outcome uh to come to scrutiny so it
needs to come to us at some
point right what was the other one um
you about mold um alen has been further
instances of mold Circle call and um
yeah let's have a look in here what I
just I I about it did
you sorry when did you email oh two
months ago I don't know about before
Christmas
yeah sorry I didn't catch that one
yeah
um the sixth largest social Housing
Association invited blah blah
blah publication of the coroner report
in yeah well the there's no information
really on that um but I
think um we need to look at the
reports that uh because
so there there was some details weren't
there that um they said that data that
they had
um around the mold they they were going
to collate it and and give us a chance
to see that um but I'll pick up on that
now yeah
okay
right um
yeah
oh yeah the so I item 10 is urgent
business don't have any um so no need
for exclusions and so on uh and that
concludes our meeting so thank you all
very
much and have a safe
journey